and i think people people need to be
willing to accept some
some truths that will hurt them
personally in other words
people are very invested in these two
parties
uh there are democrats who are very
invested in the democratic party and
republicans who are very invested in the
republican party and they see their
leaders whether it's nancy pelosi or
donald trump or whoever it might be
as um as sorts of heroes
and they have to be willing to accept
that some of these people at the top
including people that they revere are
not the heroes and i'm not trying to put
you on the spot i don't know who you
like or who you don't like
but what i'm telling you as a member of
congress because i'm in there and i see
it with my eyes i can see it
firsthand up close there are leaders
on both sides of the aisle and people
say oh don't both side stuff well this
is
this is the truth this is the truth of
what's wrong with congress
there are leaders on both sides of the
aisle who believe so strongly in the
performative aspect of government
and their primary goal is to maintain
the power they have
through this performance they're they're
more like hollywood entertainers than
anything else
and this is on both sides of the aisle
not just democrats not just republicans
it's
both republicans and democrats and it
really starts with the leadership teams
i can assure you that we could have
gotten something
through the house um and through the
senate on criminal justice reform
but there wasn't really a desire to do
so and we have to reckon
we have to reckon with that that that
actually some of the people who are
telling you let's get things
done don't want the resolution because
it's preferable to have it as a campaign
issue
or to for example not give donald trump
the win
yeah why are more members of congress
not banging the table on this and i have
a hunch
i mean it has something to do with the
performative aspects you talked about
which is if you go to the town hall and
then people are like hey we need this
and this
and like the the easy thing to do having
been a candidate um though
sometimes you know i mean obviously i
wasn't in office so like you know in
many ways
uh it was both easier and harder for me
but you say yes we have to get that done
is like the easy thing to do the hard
thing to do would be to say
and hey i guess i i have no input in
that because we're the minority party
right now and uh they have a closed
legislative process it doesn't even
allow
edmond so they just kind of serve it up
and then we like like like it's
i mean it's very hard to present the
second picture because it makes you seem
uh less like you're gonna go back there
and like do
do the you know what they want you to do
um but it sounds like the second might
be a more accurate picture for many
yeah i watch these um i'm seeing all
these campaign ads right now
and everyone's saying i'm gonna do this
i'm gonna do that i'm like no you're not
you're not gonna do that because you
have no power to do it
there the system isn't designed to let
you do that
and you ask well why don't the um
members of congress you know why don't
they talk about this and
and the the sad
truth is that the majority of them
prefer this system and
you know just to go through that a
little bit when you think about it
it's actually a pretty easy life for
them
okay they they come to congress
if they um bend the knee for leadership
and just say we'll go along with
whatever show you're doing
you know you're putting on the democrat
show or you're putting on the republican
show or whatever we'll go along with it
as long as they um you know play along
and do the performance
they are taken care of they're babied
and imagine someone i
i try to frame it this way when people
say justin why don't you run for speaker
okay well here's why they would never
choose me as speaker because i would
tell them
we're going to open up the process and
you're going to have a lot of votes
and these votes are going to be tough
they're going to put you on the spot
and instead of spending all my time
fundraising for
my particular party which is how the
speaker operates today
you know a whole bunch of time is spent
fundraising so
if i were running for speaker i'd say
guess what that's not going to be the
focus of my work my focus is going to be
making sure the institution runs
properly
it's not going to be out there raising
money for my political party if i were a
republican for example at the time
it's not going to be to go out there and
raise money for republicans or make sure
republicans win everywhere
i'm going to be focused on making sure
this institution runs smoothly
and you know what the members of
congress would say to me who are going
to vote for speaker they'd say well no
thanks
um we don't want that kind of speaker we
want the speaker
who tells us just um
you know give me your voting card and
i'll take care of everything for you
if you get attacked in your district or
you get a primary challenge
we're there for you we'll we'll spend
millions of dollars to protect you
um if you uh vote with the speaker will
give you whatever committee assignment
you want they they prefer that system
it's an easy life
uh when i go to the house floor on
average i would say the members of
congress
most of them uh 90 percent
do not actually know what we're voting
on like
they know some rough idea of what the
bill is like
they might know it's about a particular
topic but they actually don't know the
workings of the legislation
and there's no one holding them
accountable
the two numbers that i'm throwing out
there to the public justin around this
set of phenomenon you just described
congressional approval rating as a body
21 percent
re-election rate of individual members
94 you know so like
so everybody was there being like hey
let me uh make sure i get re-elected and
and then like the overall performance is
actually not that material to
my my re-election prospects
and i see this all the time by the way i
see this all the time in funny ways like
i'll be on
twitter and someone will say my uh
my favorite representatives are and then
they'll list like
uh a few who are kind of well known
and and maybe ones that even i think are
pretty good ones
and then they'll list their own
representative and i'll be like
that guy is like not this he's not the
same as these
others right but but
people think that their own
representative is great
and i think it again it has to do with
like sort of the
the messaging back home and people
falling for it
and it's not the fault of people at home
they're busy they've got their you know
they're
they're super busy with their lives um i
think probably people actually know
uh more today about politics than they
ever did in the past
so i i don't want to criticize people at
home for not knowing
uh and i don't know what to make of that
other than like you know that's
that shows that the performance works
you know the
the theater works um but
liking the person personally does not
translate to the person being a good
member of congress i mean they
there are lots of really likable people
who are terrible members of congress
and you know there are actually a few
unlikable people who are really good
members of congress so
it's i don't want to name names here
either but
but there just are there are some people
who are not that charismatic and not
that likable
and i i look at them i'm like this is a
pretty good member of congress you know
not flashy um but they they get the job
done and i can tell the person really
understands things and is working hard
justin among the other members of
congress because you've been around um
you know uh in in the chambers who else
is
similarly uh
disgusted with the current state of
affairs and wants to clean up
the mechanics like who the other members
of congress were like well if they were
in charge and they would actually be
like look let's try and make this place
work again
so um there are a lot of them who talk
privately about this and you know i'm
not sure i want to go through all the
names of my colleagues on this but
i would say that it's a it's a minority
of congress in other words
you have maybe um
a couple dozen to maybe 50 members
who really care about this and would
really welcome this kind of change uh
maybe
maybe even up to 100 members out of the
435 who would welcome the change
even if some of them aren't that focused
on it
and then the rest of them over 300 who
would not welcome
making it um actually a more open
process
or making the legislation more readable
there are people and i wouldn't say it's
um a partisan thing it's it's across the
aisle
i i know um for example i'll just give
you one prominent one
uh because it's it's not a secret or
anything aoc has
many times echoed my tweets
or like some of my tweets where i've
talked about this broken process i think
she'd welcome something more open
um i believe so it's not an it's not an
ideological
it's not like an ideological it's
something else
it's like an integrity thing right and
and
um she's another another example of um
someone who i've been impressed with
in the sense that she she votes what she
believes
um i can't speak to that on every single
vote but i have seen a number of votes
where she has been willing to buck her
party and that matters
that matters whether you agree with her
ideologically or not and i certainly
have a lot of
disagreements with her and other areas
where we agree
so i don't want to want to say it's you
know all disagreements there are lots of
areas where we
would agree but um
but at least i feel when she votes she's
she's doing it out of a place of
integrity she is
staying true to what she told her
constituents she would do
and i respect that and i think that we
need more legislators like that
it doesn't matter whether they are right
or left
i just want people who are honest i want
a a whole bunch of progressives and a
whole bunch of libertarians and a whole
bunch of conservatives let's put us all
together
and let's work through the issues in an
open and honest way
and um and there are those members out
there but they're just there's just not
that many unfortunately because the
system the system eats them up
thank you for listening in i hope you
enjoyed this conversation
if you did please do subscribe to yang
speaks and click on notifications so we
can let you know
every time we have a new episode